LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
This is an incredible place
with lots of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what it'd be like to
come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler,
and have coffee with them.
And just chat about what
they do, how they do it,
and why they do it.
And today we're going
to do exactly that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to Coffee with a Googler.
I'm Laurence Moroney and
I'm here in New York City
to meet with Roman Nurik.
And Roman Nurik is one of
our material design gurus
here at Google.
So material design, tell
me what's it all about.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh, Laurence.
What is material design?
It's kind of hard to explain.
There's actually a video with a
bunch of the original designers
that created material
design and they
get asked the same
question and they
don't know how to answer it.
It is a complex kind of thing.
There's a lot of
things going on.
I guess is the most basic
level, it's a design language.
It's a design system.
It covers visual interaction
and motion design.
I feel like most design
systems, design languages,
are treated as just
visual languages.
Like here are the colors
you should use, and so on.
But material is
much more than that.
It really kind of
covers the model,
the underlying physical
model, of the UI.
So it basically
tries to establish
this physical environment within
which your apps should live.
On a phone, on a
tablet, on a computer,
basically any sort of screen.
And then it
basically establishes
this physical
environment and a set
of basic rules and principles.
And I like to think of it along
these kind of four basic axes,
or four basic principles.
And that's tangible surfaces.
Work on the material metaphor.
We can talk about what
material is at some point.
Also bold graphic design.
This idea that we should take
some of the best design ideas
from the print world and see
how they can help us make really
great apps on digital devices.
And the third is
meaningful motion.
Basically how all these
things, how these surfaces,
and the ink on that surface,
the graphic design stuff,
how that all moves in a
consistent way to help
communicate what's going on.
And the fourth thing, which is
to me one of the most important
things, is adaptive design.
Which is how can we take
all these first three things
and make sure that
they work consistently
and coherently across different
devices, phones and tablets,
and everything else.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now
you have a video, right,
of some really good examples
of material design being used.
So should we roll that?
ROMAN NURIK: Let's roll it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: So some
pretty excellent examples there,
but it's like, "How does
somebody reach that level?"
And for someone like
me, I'm a developer
and my design skills
are nonexistent.
So if I want to
become somebody who
can build apps with
those kind of design,
how do I get started?
How do I learn this stuff?
ROMAN NURIK: That's
a great question.
I think first of all, I
just want to, I guess,
recognize some of those apps
they're doing amazing jobs.
And they have large
teams, some of them
actually have very small teams.
Some of those apps are
created by one person.
So you can absolutely
reach that level of quality
from these amazing showcase apps
regardless of your team size.
But I'd say for the
developers and designers
out there that are
just getting started,
there are a lot of great
resources out there.
There's a great Udacity course
that me, Nick Butcher, also
from Google team here, and
James Williams from Udacity
put together.
And that's available
at udacity.com/google.
And there's also a bunch
of amazing resources
on design.google.com
which will tell you
about how to come
to Android if you're
doing iOS stuff, for example.
Or how to get
started understanding
what material design is.
Obviously the entire material
design guidelines are there.
So I'd say that's the
first thing the Udacity
course is probably the best
first step in getting started.
But there's a whole lot
of resources out there
and we link to others
from the Udacity course.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And Udacity courses,
if you're not
familiar with them,
they're very Socratic
in how they teach.
It's short videos
and then challenging
you to do something.
And then a short video and then
getting you to do something.
And it's a good way to
someone can incrementally
learn rather than be thrown
into a huge design doc
or something like that.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah
it's definitely--
there's a very
clear progression.
We specifically
designed that course
so that you can kind of start
with some of the basics.
The most elementary basic
things about a screen,
like what is a pixel, what is
a density independent pixel.
And then you ramp
all the way up to how
do I make everything work on
phones, tablets, and so on.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And I have
to assume that design course is
well designed.
ROMAN NURIK: We have
some very nice color
choices in our slides or our
tablet drawings, so hopefully.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So back
to material design again.
Why material?
ROMAN NURIK: So material goes
back to that first principle.
So this idea of
tangible surfaces.
This idea that everything on
your screen and your device
exists on a surface.
We like to think of
them as pieces of paper.
So basically you can think of
basically a sheet of material
or the word material
representing
one of those pieces of paper.
And the reason we
don't just call it
paper is because it actually
is a lot more than just paper.
In the real world paper,
once you rip it up
you can't really just
put it back together.
And paper can't go from
being a circle to a square
to a rectangle.
And so we like to think of our
digital pieces of material,
or sheets of material, as
kind of a smarter paper.
Still a constrained paper,
you can just do anything.
It can't just do all
sorts of crazy things,
but it is a physical
thing that exists inside
of this kind of
environment, this kind
of like faux environment.
But it is something that has
a lot of thought put into it.
And so the word
material to me really
means, the sheets of paper
that everything in this world
exists on.
But for me is the main
thing to think about,
the reason that motion is so
important in material design
is that motion should
always have meaning.
Try not to just do it
like a flip of a button,
or like a double rotation,
or something just
to kind of draw attention.
Every time something moves
it attracts our attention
and so it needs to
be really thoughtful
and really carefully
planned out.
And so in material, we use
motion just enough motion
to convey the change
in some object's state
or try to get a little
bit of attention.
But just enough motion not
too little, not too much.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I
understand Android Studio has
some templates to
allow developers
to at least get
started with building
material design into apps.
ROMAN NURIK: Absolutely.
So one of my philosophies
for a long time has been,
we can write about
a material design,
we can write about a thing.
We can make suggestions
about that thing.
We can try to teach
people about the thing.
But one of the best ways to get
the thing into people's hands,
in this case material design,
is to actually just build it
into the tools.
Just make sure that as a
developer that's just getting
started, even just
on Android, if I just
go to File, New
Project or new app
I should be able to get
the latest and greatest.
And so in Android
Studio, now we're
actually seeing new templates
for material design.
So you could do file new project
and then your default activity
templates are going to come
with material design in them.
So it's going to use
the material theme.
It's going to use some
of the latest support
libraries for material design,
so things like the Android
Design Support Library,
things like AppCompat,
So you're just gonna get a lot
of great stuff for free right
off the bat.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
for someone like me,
I'm a coder not a designer.
But I could use Android
Studio, get the effectively
the scaffolding done for
me in these templates.
And then learn from something
like the Udacity course.
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
I definitely suggest, even
before you do the Udacity
course, file new project.
Just look around the code.
See what you get.
I think that's a great
way to get started.
I always valued as
a kid growing up
learning programming and stuff
I always valued experimentation.
So definitely
experiment with that.
But as soon as if you hit
an obstacle or something,
obviously take a look at
the guide and the reference,
and all that.
But the Udacity course
is a great way to say,
"You know what, let me just
kind of see what Google thinks
is the right way to kind
of approach understanding
this system."
LAURENCE MORONEY: Awesome.
Well thanks, Roman.
This has been a whole lot of
fun and I've learned more about
material design in the last five
minutes than I'd had in a year
before so thank you so much .
ROMAN NURIK: I can always
talk about this stuff.
LAURENCE MORONEY: They
told me that about you.
This is my favorite
thing to talk about.
ROMAN NURIK: It's been
awesome, Laurence.
Thanks.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm going to
check out that Udacity course
and I recommend
that you do so too.
And if you're an
Android developer
take a look at those templates.
If you have any questions for
me about this, or if you have
any questions for Roman
about material design,
or other aspects of building
for material design,
just please drop us a line
in the comments below.
Thank you for watching
this episode of Coffee
with a Googler.
For more great episodes
of Coffee with a Googler
and for more great videos
on the developer topics,
please tune to the Google
Developers channel on YouTube.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]